-We've been off
for a few weeks,
so there's a lot of news
we didn't get to cover.
Here to recap it for you is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good evening. You guys,
things have been crazy!
Okay. First of all,
Beyoncé and Jay-Z
dropped their joint album,
and I was like, what?!
Beyoncé was all...
♪ What?
What, what, what, what? ♪
But sometimes she was all...
♪ Wha-wha-wha-wha
wha-wha-what? ♪
And I was like, what?
Then, Trump met with the Queen,
and everyone was like,
"I can't believe he was
so inappropriate."
And I was like, what?
Did he touch her butt?
[ Laughter ]
And everyone was like, "No."
Then I was like, then shut up.
All he did was walk
in front of her.
Do you want Trump behind you?
[ Laughter ]
What if he's behind you
right now?
You looked, didn't you?
[ Laughter ]
He's not back there.
You're fine.
Then something crazy happened.
Papa John got caught saying
the N-word on a conference call,
and I was like, what?!
[ Laughter ]
Caught?
It was a conference call.
You didn't get caught.
You got heard!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Then when people got mad,
he said he was --
and I am not kidding --
"forced to use it."
And I was like, what?
Someone forced you
to say the N-word?
You can't force someone
to say the N-word.
Watch.
Hey, Seth, say the N-word.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Say it now.
-No, and don't cut back
to me anymore.
-Do it!
-No!
-See? You can't make
someone say it.
Then, I heard a CVS manager
called the cops
on a black lady
for trying to use a coupon,
and I was like, what?
Because they always treat me
like a queen at CVS.
And by that, I mean they're
always walking behind me.
[ Laughter ]
And...
♪ The black people clapped
and the white people got sad ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, a raccoon climbed
a building.
And I was like, what...
are my nightmares doing
coming to life?
And people were like,
isn't that cute?
Amd I was like, what?
The building?
I guess, for a building.
And they were like,
"No, the raccoon."
And I was like, if I saw this
outside my office window,
I'd ask him to scoot over
so I can jump to my death.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Seth, say it.
-No!
-Okay.
Then the best thing
in the world happened.
Congresswoman Maxine Waters
was talking about
how she was receiving
death threats and said...
-If you shoot me, you better
shoot straight.
There's nothing like
a wounded animal.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-[ Laughs ] What?!
[ Applause ]
I was like, what a cold-blooded
thing to say!
For the win!
Then, an interviewer
asked Serena Williams
if she was "intimidated by
Maria Sharapova's good looks."
And I was like, what...
the hell kind of question
is that?
Why would she be intimidated
by her good looks?
Sorry. I had to use
all three pictures
because I have no idea
which tennis player
"Marie Sharapovy" is,
and I'm slowly forgetting
her name.
[ Applause ]
This one?
I think it's this one.
I don't know.
Also, what are you doing
asking Serena Williams
if she's intimidated
by another tennis player?
There's only one woman
we're all intimidated by,
and that's this woman.
This has been
"Seth Says the N-Word."
-No!
-This has been
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give it up for Amber Ruffin,
everybody!